I feel that your wisdom would really be
helpful for certain people who are
content creators do you
[Music]
you got famous very quickly and I'll say
that as someone who had the same form of
success I turned into a real animal I
mean you know well not a real animal but
uh I'd like to ask how you stay grounded
you know Drew Fame came later to me in
life I got myself 10 years Young when
The Tick Tock is done and the
multi-colored foes you know are put away
what sparks joy for you I'm very normal
what's in the park taking care of my
little baby brother and you know I will
sit back and sometimes watch my own
tiktoks oh so you do watch yourself I
know some people don't but I believe in
being your own number one fan I never
knew whether I should ever you know
watch my own movies I even wondered if I
should show them to my kids and then
eventually they saw some and now they
call them mom movies which is really
sweet it's funny you know I haven't
shown them Beverly Hills Chihuahua which
I have to say I went into major method
for I take it really seriously now the
internet can be a very difficult place
to navigate how do you say positive
so I just got to make sure I stay
surrounded by people I love at home
friends and family and remember that
it's real life that counts not what's
online how do you stay grounded and
remember what's important I'm still a
little lady that works on four legs so
I'm quite close to the ground to begin
with
that's good I like that are you on any
dating apps you know Drew I've been
single for 10 years and I plan to keep
it that way I make myself happiest so
why would I leave that responsibility to
someone else I have wondered why I've
been single for six years and I am so
happy and content and hearing it come
from you well it just makes me feel
better about myself you have impeccable
fashion sense I'd like for you to give a
piece of fashion advice that we can all
follow as much as I love my passion to
be fun and flirty I always put Comfort
first you don't find too itchy but
effect underneath all my two dresses
there is always a layer of velvet to
keep me nice and cozy well that's a hot
tip right there okay chica as a last
question at the end of the day how do
you unwind how do you unleash I see what
you did there Drew I have five fluffy
pillows to choose from so I'll take my
time choosing one get a nice cozy
blanket and then block out the rest of
the world for about 22 to 23 hours a day
and what is your advice on how to
maximize two hours in a day number one
make your photo shoots very quick 30
seconds to 2 minutes maximum eat as much
as you can bathroom break rehydrate and
then back to bed we go gosh Tikka you
are so smart thank you for adding me
Drew I love these types of conversations
among powerful women
thank you
[Music]